arriving at Tel Aviv airport the U.S
Secretary of State is visiting at a time
of high tension but with few
expectations U.S diplomacy can do
anything to help he spoke about recent
violence to take an innocent life in an
act of terrorism is always
a heinous crime
but to Target people outside their place
of worship
is especially shocking
a reference to the death of seven
Israelis near a synagogue at an East
Jerusalem settlement on Thursday it's
notable he spoke about incidents in
which Israelis died but didn't mention
the raid Janine refugee camp last
Thursday a day on which 10 Palestinians
were killed
before secretary blinking got here there
was another death a Palestinian man shot
dead by Israeli forces as he drove his
car in the city of Hebron
Mr blinking has met Benjamin Netanyahu
many times before but this is the first
meeting since he became head of Israel's
most right-wing government ever the
Secretary of State said there must be a
future where Israelis and Palestinians
can live peacefully side by side we
continue to believe that the best way to
achieve it is through preserving
and then realizing the vision of two
states as I said to the Prime Minister
anything that moves us away from that
vision is in our judgment detrimental to
Israel's long-term security and its
long-term identity as a Jewish and
Democratic state
but the reality is that Mr Netanyahu and
his key ministers don't support the idea
of a two-state solution he didn't
mention Palestinians once and instead
focused on the threat from Iran most of
the International Community have seen
the true face of Iran they've seen the
barbarism of this regime against its own
people they've seen how it exports
aggression Beyond its border and Beyond
the Middle East and I think there's a
common consensus that this regime must
not acquire nuclear weapons secretary
blinken will continue his meetings with
Israeli officials on Tuesday he'll also
make a brief visit to Ramallah to meet
with the president of the Palestinian
Authority Mahmoud Abbas many in the
International Community would like the
Biden Administration to take a more
proactive diplomatic role in this
conflict but so far there's no sign of a
change in the U.S position James Bay's
Al Jazeera occupied East Jerusalem